The 2018 superhero body count was impressive,
and 2019's butcher's bill promises to stack
at least as high.
Last year, the genre didn't really give us
impressive numbers until the release of Avengers:
Infinity War.
Meanwhile, the ranks of the capes have already
been seriously thinned in 2019.
Warning: Spoilers ahead
First appearing in 2016's Suicide Squad #3,
the bizarre Cosmonut was a member of Russia's
Annihilation Brigade.
The Brigade tried and failed to stop the Squad
from escaping after they broke into an underground
prison.
But in Suicide Squad #50, Cosmonut sacrificed
himself for his old adversaries.
With Amanda Waller rendered a giant, mindless
beast that could breathe fire, Harley Quinn
and Rick Flag were not much of a match.
In an uncharacteristic move, Cosmonut saved
his old enemies by holding off Waller.
Quinn and Flag eventually managed to find
the rest of the Squad and restore Waller to
her old form, but not in time to save Cosmonut.
Before losing her powers, Waller melted his
big metal hammer head.
“Damn, that is just one mean lady.
“Yeah”
Glass saw all of its super-guys killed in
a single scene.
Unfortunately, that includes David Dunn, who
had been known as the vigilante Overseer since
2000's Unbreakable.
In the final battle between Dunn and the Beast,
the latter - having learned from Elijah that
Dunn's weakness is water - hurls himself and
Dunn into a huge plastic water tank.
The tank proves too brittle for the struggle
and shatters, freeing them both and flooding
a large pothole.
After Dunn's son Joseph begs policemen to
help his father, one of the policemen shoves
Dunn's face into the pothole.
Dr. Ellie Staple rushes to Dunn and tells
him to hold her hand.
He does, and his power allows him to see a
memory of Staple's, a meeting of a secret
society dedicated to keeping people with powers
in check.
She tells Dunn if she'd convinced him that
he never had powers, he would've been allowed
to live.
The policeman pushes Dunn's face back into
the water, drowning him.
"A lot of people are going to die."
A star athlete paralyzed by a bullet during
a peaceful protest, Khalil Payne fell under
the sway of the power-hungry Tobias Whale,
who funded surgery that restored Khalil's
ability to walk and gave him powers.
Whale treated Khalil like a son at first,
and in return Khalil served Whale as Painkiller.
He used poisoned darts to attack random former
classmates, eventually fighting and defeating
Black Lightning himself.
After Whale's treatment of Khalil turns ugly
and abusive, Khalil finally finds the courage
to turn on Whale and run away with his ex-girlfriend
Jen.
Khalil agrees to go home, turn himself in,
and enter witness protection.
Whale hijacks Khalil's transport and confronts
his former protege, ripping Khalil's cybernetic
spine out of his back with his bare hands.
While Khalil clings to life following Whale's
brutal attack, Jen convinces her psychic teacher,
Perenna, to ease Khalil's passing by placing
the couple in a dream world where they're
on their way to the prom.
February's Uncanny X-Men #11 represented the
first reunion of Cyclops and the newly resurrected
Wolverine.
But while it gave the X-Men back two of their
favorite sons, it also stole away two lesser-known
daughters.
The first victim was the young, future-seeing
Blindfold, real name Ruth.
In the wake of almost all of the X-Men disappearing
in previous issues, Blindfold was one of the
few allies both Wolverine and Cyclops were
able to contact while looking for survivors.
Unfortunately, she was seeing bleak and disturbing
images of the future, causing her to feel
utterly hopeless.
Scott Summers finds Ruth has committed suicide
in her bathtub, cryptically writing "This
is forever" on the wall in her own blood.
Ruth first entered the X-Men mythos courtesy
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer creator Joss Whedon
and artist John Cassaday's game-changing Astonishing
X-Men run, when Ruth predicted the tragic
suicide of fellow Xavier student Wing.
Loa's death is portrayed strangely, particularly
for a superhero character.
We see little of the events leading up to
it, don't know who killed Loa or how it happened.
Held hostage by Blindfold's random "memory"
of what has happened, what is happening, and
what's to come, we find Velocidad and Blindfold
standing over the corpse of Loa in the snow.
We don't know exactly how she died or exactly
who killed her.
Considering the events of the rest of Uncanny
X-Men #11, which shows how jubilant anti-mutant
groups like the Purifiers are in the wake
of the X-Men's disappearance, it seems likely
a mutant-hating group was responsible for
Loa's death, but we don't know for sure.
The feel of the issue, particularly Blindfold's
chapter, suggests the confusion will be cleared
up soon.
As The Gifted's second season reaches its
climax, Marcos, a.k.a. Eclipse, meant to capture
and interrogate Inner Circle stooge Max about
the group's plans, but Max fights back and
forces Marcos to use deadly force.
That leads Inner Circle head Reeva to search
for the traitor who led the Mutant Underground
to Max.
She blames the wrong person.
Not knowing that Polaris has learned to use
her magnetic powers to hack computer systems,
Reeva and the Frost sisters blame Sage, whose
powers revolve around computer systems and
whose digital signature they find.
Sage pleads her innocence, but Reeva is unconvinced.
She uses her sonic powers with her usual mercilessness,
killing Sage.
While Sage is innocent of betraying the Inner
Circle in The Gifted, her comic book counterpart
was a spy for Professor X, infiltrating the
infamous Hellfire Club.
Early in the current run of Batman, the Caped
Crusader comes across two heroes he thinks
might act as replacements in his mission to
safeguard Gotham.
The brother/sister team of Gotham and Gotham
Girl have Superman-like powers and idolized
Batman.
They'd subjected themselves to experiments
to gain their powers, and those powers were
slowly killing them.
Gotham dies and Batman does what he could
to help Gotham Girl.
In the mini-event "The Price," Gotham Girl
returns with a plan for vengeance, a mystery
benefactor, and her brother resurrected.
Gotham's return is short-lived, though.
In battle with the Flash, Gotham quickly overextends
himself and again dies, literally exploding.
If Blindfold and Loa weren't enough, the following
week in Uncanny X-Men #12, former X-Factor
member Guido, a.k.a.
Strong Guy, falls.
Still looking for surviving X-Men, Cyclops
and Wolverine learn that mutants were being
imprisoned and used to power a new kind of
Sentinel.
Freeing Strong Guy, Mirage, and others from
their Sentinel suits, Cyclops and Wolverine
lead a raid on the prison to free the remaining
mutants.
On their way out of the prison, a copy of
Multiple Man discovers he had been booby trapped
with a bomb.
Guido uses his body to absorb the blast and
protect his allies.
Already weakened by a techno-organic virus,
Guido didn't survive the blast.
Still being pursued, the X-Men were forced
to leave their friend's massive body behind.
Reed Strucker (The Gifted) February 26, 2019
When active, Reed Strucker's powers caused
anything he touched to disintegrate, which
unintentionally jeopardized his own safety
and that of everyone around him.
He'd managed to use his powers consciously
once or twice, but for the most part they
eluded his control.
He went so far as to suppress them with drugs.
"I have this ability and there's nothing I
can do with it."
In the season finale, Reed uses his lack of
control to a noble end.
When the Mutant Underground raids the Inner
Circle's headquarters to stop Reeva from sparking
a mutant/human war, Reed slips past her security
and confronts her.
Knowing Reeva's sonic powers would make his
abilities even more unpredictable, Reed cuts
loose, utterly destroying the top floors of
the Inner Circle's building, killing himself
and Reeva in the process.
Most readers knew one team member would bite
the dust by the end of X-Force #4.
Previews of the cover showed the teenage Cable
cradling what appeared to be an obscured corpse.
The obvious choice was Deathlok who appeared
mortally wounded by the mutant-hunting Ahab
in the previous issue.
Deathlok gets better, though.
Then Ahab nearly disembowels Shatterstar with
Wolverine-ish claws he'd taken from Deathlok.
But Shatterstar gets better, too, and it looks
like the cover might've just been big one
big tease.
Ahab and his mutant-hating ally are both dead
when finally, on the second-to-last page,
an energy portal appears behind Warpath and
he's impaled through the chest by some kind
of energized rod.
Warpath collapses to the ground and the final
page reveals a splash of X-Force's old enemy
Stryfe emerging from the portal, presumably
ready to send the rest of X-Force to join
Warpath in the afterlife.
Asgardians of the Galaxy has proven to be
a lot of fun.
A team of Asgardian and Asgardian-themed heroes
forms to stop Nebula from bringing about universal
Ragnarok.
The Asgardians are led by the deadly Angela
and includes Skurge the Executioner; Valkyrie;
Thunderstrike; and Throg, Frog of Thunder.
The team also included the deadly Destroyer
armor, and by the end of the first issue it
was revealed that the armor was hiding and
protecting Kid Loki, a younger and even more
insufferable version who emerged as a result
of the original Loki's death in 2010.
There is some mystery behind how Kid Loki
dies in Asgardians of the Galaxy #7, because
it isn't a result of that issue's events.
Angela finds Kid Loki lounging on the branch
of a tree.
He tells her he can't go with her because
his older counterpart - who did eventually
return - has dismissed the spell that brought
him into being.
Kid Loki simply vanishes into nothing.
War of the Realms #1 ends with a major Asgardian
death.
As Malekith's forces finally attack Earth
and the heroes of New York City rally, King
Laufey of the Frost Giants targets Freyja,
mother of Thor and wife of Odin.
The giant has the Asgardian queen trapped
when Loki appears and separates his biological
dad's hand from the rest of his arm with a
glowing green sword.
Calling Loki his, quote, "one great shame,"
Laufey seizes his son and devours him.
Loki's presumed death here seems particularly
unceremonious for a character this popular,
not to mention the fact that he's just started
appearing in a kind of "buddy cop" miniseries
with Wolverine called Wolverine: Infinity
Watch, which isn't even halfway through its
run yet.
Plus, Loki's getting a new solo series in
July.
In Avengers: Endgame, Black Widow and Hawkeye
are half of the team sent back to 2014, where
they're assigned to get the Soul Stone.
Though Nebula gives the Avengers the location
of the Soul Stone, she unfortunately doesn't
know what it will take to claim it.
"The stone demands a sacrifice."
Widow and Hawkeye arrive on Vormir and quickly
encounter the Red Skull.
When he explains the Stone's price, Clint
and Natasha argue over who should die.
Clint feels his actions as Ronin have turned
him into a monster, while Nat doesn't see
anything worth living for beyond the found
family Thanos' purge stole from her.
The argument turns physical, with Clint throwing
himself over the cliff.
Widow follows him and winds up dangling over
a fatal drop with only Clint's grip keeping
her from falling.
She begs Clint to let her go, and she eventually
falls to her death.
Just like Thanos in Infinity War, Clint wakes
in a shallow pool with the Soul Stone.
Early in Avengers: Endgame's final battle,
Tony Stark asks Doctor Strange if this was
the possible outcome Strange saw in which
the good guys win.
"How many do we win?"
"One."
Strange refuses to answer at first.
After Thanos captures the new Infinity Gauntlet,
Strange mutely signals to Tony with one index
finger.
Stark rushes Thanos, who easily brushes him
aside.
But once Thanos snaps, we learn that the point
of Tony's attack was to steal the Stones.
Showing the gathered Stones on his suit's
gauntlet, Stark snaps his fingers and the
Mad Titan's forces turn to dust.
Thanos slumps to the ground and is purged
from existence.
Tony doesn't have the strength to survive
using the stones.
As he struggles, Pepper summons the courage
to smile and tell him they're all going to
be fine, and that he can rest now.
Tony dies and the light in the Arc Reactor
in his chest blinks out.
At the end of the credits, you can hear Tony's
hammer striking the anvil while making his
first suit in 2008's Iron Man.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about superheroes
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.